each image is a revolution in astronomy
the james webb telescope has seen deeper
into the universe than ever before
revealed new details of the death of a
star like our sun
exposed the black hole at the heart of a
distant dusty galaxy seen water in the
atmosphere of a planet more than a
thousand light years from earth
and these are just its first five images
no wonder they were more than a little
excited at nasa its boss arriving to
scientists turn cheerleaders dressed up
as the telescope's 18 gold-plated
mirrors these are just the first
glimpses
imagine what we're going to learn over
the course of 20 years
uh think of uh
the answers that we're going to get to
questions that we don't even know what
the questions are
it is extraordinary
there was hype around these images but
the faces of the scientists and
engineers seeing them for the first time
don't lie if you're any doubt about how
significant these new images are i wish
you could be in this room because around
me are the scientists the
astrophysicists the cosmologists who
really understand how they've changed
our view of the universe not only can
they see things in incredible new detail
already just with these first five
images we've seen things we've never
seen before i think one of the great
things about this telescope is how
efficient it is we're able to get this
this kind of data in a fraction of the
time that we were before so i think a
lot of the records that we have in the
current day universe those are going to
be broken really soon
there was a sense of relief too the webb
telescope is the largest ever put in
space it took 20 years and 10 billion
dollars to design and build and it was
nearly cancelled many times
even after launch hundreds of things
could have gone wrong as it unfolded
itself a million miles from earth there
are many moments where i was really
really worried about the future
including at the beginning frankly even
five six years ago where we were
standing still burning money we could
not make progress and we needed to build
an amazing team there were many moments
like that but all of them are behind us
now and the
sky is open for us
within days we're expecting webb to give
us a new view of the planets in our
solar system within weeks see the very
first light that illuminated the
universe 13.5 billion years ago and it's
expected to work for another 20 years
so prepare to be amazed
tom clark sky news maryland